So the core task of what we will do in
this course is to teach a computer to
learn a function. This function will be
learned from a set of examples. We start
with a data set D. Basically the set of
input and output. These outputs are the
desired outputs. We want later when the
computer sees new access that follows
the same distribution as D can predict
this desired output. So assume just to
formalize this that we have n of these
examples that we can use to learn this
function. So this function should be
flexible enough that can characterize
all of these relationships that are
between X and Y. So for example, a data
matrix of n rows and each one of these
observation or samples has the features
in for example a classification task. We
want to classify each one of these
samples into a class zero or one. So y
will take a shape like a vector of n
dimension of zero and ones. But we can
also have a regression where basically f
is a function from um x to a real value.
So like I said, we want f to be flexible
enough that when later we give an x i
that we never saw in the training, but
we know that x i is following the same
probability as uh training data, we want
our flexible f to predict uh the desired
output. So why this is a difficult
problem? One main reason is f should be
flexible like I said but at the same
time we can have many f that can satisfy
this condition. However we want one of
them that maybe is most suited to our
case or performs best in this specific
context. So to come up with that f
sometimes we need to give the algorithm
an inductive bias to basically go toward
the f the type of f that we want. In our
previous courses for example in linear
regression we chose a linear model to be
the class that our f belongs to. So this
type of f basically assumes the world is
linear and it can fail when we have a
complex data that is not following that
wall. We will call this situation a high
bias situation where we are very off
from the real data. The model is off.
The model is simple. So it will have low
variance. But of course this strong bias
is not desirable. In deep neural
networks, we have a weak bias, meaning
that F is much more flexible. Um, this
flexibility lets it learn complex
patterns. But of course, this comes with
a risk of overfeeding. So, we should be
always alert on how to deal with this.
This is a case of high variance and low
bias. And sometimes neural networks are
actually able to memorize the entire
training data. and then when you deploy
into the test data they will perform
poorly. Okay. So let's assume uh a class
for our f that we want our f to to
follow that class. So often time we will
uh parameterize this family or this
class by a set of tuning parameters. So
W you can think of W like a tuning par
and when when we have a given input this
function will give us yi right the
desired output. So when we have a very
good tuning for such function so let's
call this good tuning our estimation of
that W or that set of parameters. So we
want to find or estimate such W that can
work well to this unseen data and we
want to be able to assign a label that
is an accurate label or good enough
label that is close to what we want. So
we want to learn this W. Then the
problem of learning here is finding or
estimating this W's and then we want
such function to be able to do inference
for us. So inference is prediction of
this label in the unseen data. So these
are the lingos that we are going to use.
So with that I'm going to focus on the
linear regression. Just to do a recap
during this I will call some of these
concepts that we learned there and we
are going to use later in during the
course.
So in linear regression we assume a
linear relationship between y and x. So
we wrote this linear relationship like
this. So basically what this gives us is
a hyper plane in the space of x. And for
example in the case of classification
for a X that is two-dimensional nice
ukidian uh two-dimensional space this
will give us a linear plane that
basically separate the space in two
part. So for example maybe the positive
part can be from this part. Like I said
the uh the equation that determines this
decision boundary is this linear uh
equation. So what we want to completely
define the cyerspace is the weights and
this bias. So this the weight
specifically defines the slope of the
hyperspace.
So let's talk about how we can uh
determine or estimate W's that can do
well on some loss functions that we we
want for this specific linear case. We
need to basically say what is not a good
hyper plane or we need to quantify an
error in this regression case. So one
standard choice is the mean squared
error. So MSE or mean squared error can
be written as 1 n the number of samples
I minus the function that we estimated.
So here yi is the real supervision
signal or the desired output and we are
going to use the squared error over all
of these samples or examples that we
have. So remember that we want the loss
to be minimized over all of this
examples. So we call this an MSE error
and I'm going to just assign a value
here a loss that is a function of the W
and B. So sometimes during the course
you will see that I want to simplify the
algebra and I basically uh consolidate w
and b into uh into one w and how I'm
doing this I basically augment x that
initially if you remember in this case
of linear regression was a n by d matrix
I add a column of ones basically
augmented to that which will be the
initial x and then the column one which
makes the new x uh n by d + one. So by
doing that I have a new w which is now
augmented uh with b which is previous w
and a b at the end. So this way the
algebra will be easier. I basically got
rid of uh B by uh sending it into the W
and this way I can rewrite this
equation. So this way everything will be
easier and simpler. Okay. So whenever
you saw that doesn't mean that we don't
have B means that B is already in uh W
even in the neural network architectures
follow the same notation. Okay. So going
back to this loss function I again
simplify uh by basically write this in a
matrix horror. If you remember in linear
models we found the best W's W in the
sense of ordinary le square
um by minimizing this loss over all of
these W's. Right? So to do that we took
the gradient and we force it to be zero
and we found the w that makes this
equation or satisfy this equation. In
the linear case this can be done in
analytic way. So this is nice. This is a
closed form analytic equation. We can
solve this for small data sets and when
linear function is a good function. uh
the complexity of this um solution is in
D3
and that means that for very high
dimensional
um data this will be very expensive and
on the other hand if we have a um
complex model we cannot do this this is
only doable when the linearity
uh is satisfied so for what we want
doing scores. This is not uh reachable.
We cannot use this because we have none
of those those luxuries. Our data sets
are often very large and our models are
not linear.
So we have to come up with other ways of
doing this uh finding this w
and as we will discuss later we will use
a different form of gradient descent.
So going back to what we did here.
So basically what we are doing we are
minimizing the distance between our y
and our prediction using the model. So
if I want to give u a geometric
interpretation to this uh basically we
want to minimize the distance between y
and the model prediction for all of our
examples.
And we call this basically the error for
each one of these examples. And here in
this case this is a vector E. And what
happens here is basically we have a
hyperspace defined by our linear
regression.
And uh um like I said uh this is uh the
column space
so of x give us a basis for this uh uh
hyperspace
and we want a prediction that is
living in this uh column space. we
cannot go outside of that and we predict
the value of y using this prediction. So
if y happens to be outside of this
hyperspace we cannot basically
exactly go there because that will fall
outside of this uh basis. So our linear
regression because it is living in the
common space of X cannot exactly predict
Y but it will project Y into to the
hyper plane and there will be some error
remaining that our model is not able to
explain. So that's the error that as I
said it is uh perpendicular to column
space of x
and uh we want to minimize this error by
adjusting the slope and the bias our
model parameters.
So continuing on the linear regression
and the linear model I want to introduce
the concept of bias variance and how we
we do this tradeoff between these two.
So to do that let's write the error of a
found that we found previously. So in a
in a more general case, this error is
the expected
um error that if we get a new example
that we never saw, but it is following
the same distribution as uh the data
that we trained our model on and want to
minimize the error of such unseen
examples using our model. We do our best
using the the data that we had. So, so
we have the same uh loss function and
and just to simplify the algebra here, I
just write it this way. Uh basically use
the properties of expectation, we can
write this in this way. So this is uh
the composition of uh that error of the
model for designing data. So like I said
there will be some red reducible error
but we cannot do anything about using
our linear model. So that they will
remain. So we cannot do much about that
anyway. So let's focus on this
decomposed components. The first part we
call this the bias
and the second part is the variance. So
bias what bias does is it basically
measures how far is the average model
prediction from the truth
and this distance is because of some
inherent assumption that we did that
limited the the model uh expressivity to
basically predict that for example in
this case of linear regression linearity
is that limiting assumption
And we can say a simple model on complex
data is systematically wrong or in other
word it is underfeitting
to the data because of this uh basically
observed bias.
The variance on the other side measures
how much the prediction would change if
we collect a fresh training set.
In other words, the model's sensitivity
to sampling noise. On the other hand,
variance measures how much the
prediction would change if we collect a
fresh train set. Uh that means that how
much uh the model is sensitive to the
noise in sampling. error from
sensitivity to such small fluctuation in
the training set uh can be accumulate
especially if our complex model somehow
feed to this noise. So we call this
situation overfeeding.
So I keep saying that we evaluate the
model eventually in uh data that the
models have not seen. So that's why we
we split this data set into different uh
splits of training data validation
and test. So basically what we do is we
allow the model to see the training data
completely and we use the validation
data to to decide but for the tradeoff
of the bias and variance and um
basically hope for the best when we
prepare the the model this way when the
model is deployed to the test data when
the model has not seen it uh it will
perform perform the best. So that's how
we usually deal
uh with uh with the data splitting. And
like I said in the case of um if we have
the model complexity
on the x-axis
and we increase the model and often time
in the train uh when we increase the
complexity of the model we have a much
better feat over
more complex models. So this will be the
error and this is the fit to the
training data right. So but we kept a
validation data to basically tell us how
good is this how much this feat will
stand the test of unseen data. And often
time what we see in the linear models
and other models like that is a
validation error that behave like this.
So the reason is basically that this
area is the area that we have this
underfeeding. We can still improve the
feeding but then after that when we
continue adding complexity to our model
there will be an area that we overfeed.
By overfeitting I mean we basically the
we let the model to learn a fluctuation
in the in the data the noise in the data
that is not necessarily part of the
signal and once we deploy the model to
this validation data or later in the
test data we will see the model is uh
over feet and there will be a high
variance. So if I want to add the
variance here, initially the variance
would be small because of the simple
model but then the v variance will start
increasing and at some exploding. So
that's the usual u curve of bias and
variance. So it's important to to know
that this u shape diagram is not a law
of nature. So we can do techniques, we
can deploy uh better models that can re
reshape this. I mean for example we can
have of course more data that can allow
our model to have a good better
training. We can have ways to u make
sure our model is not uh getting more
complex for no reason. So we inject some
regular regularity into the model. So we
call this regularization.
Of course this will need some uh some
intuition some maybe even domain
knowledge uh that basically allow us to
come up with some engineering decision.
For example the type of regularization
or uh during the training for example we
can think of uh decaying weights. we can
think of early stopping of training. So
those are techniques that we'll talk
about during the course. So another
technique that uh is also can be
discussed is the inductive uh bias that
I did I uh explained previously in the
choice of the model family possibly have
a better inductive bias in our choice of
model selection. So this way we can
again improve the situation that is
plotted in this U-shaped diagram. So
examples of these techniques we can talk
about for example uh bridge regression
that we learned in uh linear models.
lasso for example and other types of um
regularization in training neural
networks for example dropouts data
augmentation ensembling uh that all
basically do the same thing and what
they do is to nudge the learning
dynamics to go to our parameters that
behave more consistently across possible
data sets so That's what we do here. Um,
if we fix the model, meaning that if we
have if we choose our inductive bias and
if we choose the type of regularization,
adding more data will improve the model
performance. For example, if we have n
examples,
uh, the variance will decay with a rate
of 1 / n. And it's important to note
that the bias will uh not be changed by
adding more data. But if we change the
model itself, then we can talk about the
bias changes. So that's the the two most
important distinction between these two
and how we are controlling them.
So just to complete the the discussion,
let's go back to our way of
um finding W and we we said that we are
going to use this loss function
and um uh why we are choosing this loss
in the case of linear regression. We can
zoom in into this and basically the so
basically the assumption is we have a
linear process where we can explain
using a linear model and there is a
noise that is Gaussian and our line
linear model is not able to explain. So
there is a noise and it's a standard
noise and this implies a conditional
probability meaning that having X
W and B will give us
Y
that is follows is following a normal
distribution because of that box that
the linear model cannot explain. So this
conditional probability basically tell
us that how likely is to see this
desired output given X and the model
parameters. So we want to maximize this
likelihood. How can we write this? We
basically can write this in in this way.
We want every sample to be likely. So
for all samples we have this likelihood
and we want to maximize this. So we know
from before that it's the same as
maximizing the log of this probabilities
which in that case if we take log of
this. So if I call this the MLE of uh
beta given W and B,
we can also work with log of MLE
which is uh the log of this product
which becomes uh sum of all of these log
of probabilities. Right? We have a
Gaussian distribution. We can rewrite
this as a a Gaussian distribution which
you can write this way. And if you plug
this in, you will see that this sum will
be this is basically the loss that we
will deal with.
If you remember I said we want to
maximize this MLE and here log
MLE
which is equal to minimizing this
uh list square loss. So that's why we
chose list square in the linear
regression. So why I said that? Uh
basically I want to say that the choice
of loss requires uh some prearch uh loss
basically dictates the uh the
performance of the model. We want to say
we want to tell the model that you're a
bad model because you are not doing good
in this basically set of example and the
model has to find a way to improve and
the laws is the guiding principle. So
choice of laws is important and we have
to talk about that.
Okay. Now we have a clear objective. We
want to minimize this loss function. And
to do that, we can play with our weights
or tune the knobs of these weights that
give us this minimum value. So we are
looking for weights that can minimize
this function, this loss function.
What's the challenge here? The challenge
is in modern neural networks, W can be
billions of parameters.
And this last function also can be a
very complex and non-convex function. So
what's the solution? Before presenting
the solution, I want to invite you to
think of about um the geometry of this.
So basically assume we have um parameter
space w and we have a value of loss. Of
course, this is very simplified,
but let's assume we want to find this
minimum here.
And um to do that
u assume yourself assume you are here
blindfolded and you want to basically
find that point. Uh so you start from uh
this peak here and first you feel the
slope under your feet and that's
basically like computing the gradient
the slope of that uh curvature here and
then you start taking steps. So here for
example you start taking steps this way
and you continue until you reach to some
point that um basically you feel like
this is the valley but we know that
there is a better solution here. So how
can we get there? So the mathematical
formulation of this hill climbing
intuition is called gradient descent.
And the idea is in each step we update
the previous parameters or the previous
weights of our neural network
with one step of this gradient
that is a function of the previous
weights of course. Okay. Here assume we
have the previous weight
and we want to update this. So we need
to compute uh this gradient here and as
we know the gradient can be computed
from this as function by looking at the
average
gradient per example. So we need to
compute this for all of these examples
that we have in the data. Um what's the
issue here? So the issue is we can have
a very large data set in modern data
sets like I said we have millions to
billions of examples.
On the other side large modern neural
networks can have very very large uh
set of parameters. We are thinking of
pro possibly billions of uh parameters.
So computing one
gradient step like this requires looking
at every single example and that can
take a long time. And for training a
neural network, we need to take
thousands of steps to get to this point
that we desire. So we need to change our
strategy to scale this up. So instead of
just doing a gradient descent, we are
proposing stochastic gradient descent.
So the idea is we don't really need the
exact gradient. A good approximation is
enough. So that means that instead of
solving this very expensive sum, we
approximate uh this using much smaller
random mini batch. Meaning that instead
of meaning that instead of doing this
for all examples,
we will do it for a subset of these
examples that we choose randomly. We
call this subset a batch and a batch is
much smaller
than the total number of uh examples
that we have in the data. So we are
thinking of some values like for example
32 compared to one hand that can be 1
million.
So why this works? Why opting for much
smaller uh batch size can give us still
a good gradient step. So the the key
idea is this mini batch gradient is
unbiased. In other word the expectation
of a gradient step direction and size is
equal the total gradient. So the proof
is actually very simple. Um you can
think of it basically if we randomly
sample each example and that means that
each example has an equal chance of
being selected. The expected
contribution of example I to each mini
badge is basically the average overall
of this data set. So a few things to
consider here that can um deviate from
the theoretical proof is we are looking
at each example
and basically randomly sample each
example but we are not keep putting it
back. This is not a sampling with
replacement. Uh there are practical
reasons for this. One is we want to look
at all of these examples as much as
possible and not looking at an example
multiple times.
And also we want to basically have an
average contribution
uh equally uh
distributed for all of these examples.
However, this uh sampling without
replacement somehow affects this proof.
So, this proof is not real uh is uh for
the case of uh sampling with
replacement. So, just consider that and
you should know that this is a active
field of research on how to make this
more theoretically rigorous. So if we
want to give u an algorithm for this uh
stoastic gradient descent. So we have to
first shuffle the training data. Then
divide
uh the training data into mini batches
of some selected size B. Then for each
mini batch we do the following.
We first compute the gradient then we
average them and then we update the
parameters and we repeat this process
for multiple epochs. So this will give
us um random really noisy uh step toward
the optimum and the main reason is
because we are randomly choosing this
subsamples or batches and this will give
us a noisy step and this noisy nature of
stoastic gradient descent um has uh two
maybe more general zone
uh of behavior when we are very far from
let's say we have um uh two weights. Our
neural network for some reason has two
weights and there is like a very nice
spot that this the values that this two
uh weights can take and our loss will
take some minimum value. So this is like
maybe a hole in the space the value that
we were talking about. So when we are
taking the the stochastic descent
outside of this um
uh kind of uh close area to the optimum
all of these steps are somehow uh
directing toward that. Meaning that's
basically the the idea of unbiased
direction that uh uh no matter what you
do and what random sample you do the
gradient descent has a pretty confident
step toward the optimum.
So it may not be the direct path but in
average if you take all of these p uh
steps you will get there.
And then once you are there that area is
not that certain anymore and this is
called region of confusion
for this
SGD steps and uh this may look like uh
this is not desirable. This is uh maybe
not economic. Basically there we can
have uh directions that are not
necessarily to this um optimal point
that uh we want to target. But as you
will see this actually give the
algorithm a nice property of um that
helps the model to avoid getting stuck
in poor local minima
and also this leads to solutions that
generates better to new unseen data.
prevents the model from memorizing the
training set and that basically if you
remember that will help to generalize
for unseen test data. So basically
this equips SGD to escape this bad
minima.
Okay. So we discussed how to uh come up
with a scalable way to compute this
gradient steps using a smaller subset or
a batch of data. Uh so as you see we
have two engineering decisions here.
What can be a good step size and what
can be a good batch size. So as you will
see you uh during the training of your
neural networks those two decisions can
change the performance of the neural
network training. So alpha or the step
size is also known as the learning rate
and it controls how big step sizes are.
Typical learning rates will be values
for example between um very small values
to 0.1. If I want to give you a rule of
thumb, I would start with 01 and then
adjust this based on the behavior of my
training. So why this can matter the
size? Well, imagine the same u hill
climbing uh analogy. If you start from
here, for example, a small um step size
can be very small and very slow toward
the optimal. A large step size on the
other hand can jump and overshoot
somewhere else and that also may not be
optimal. But if you come up with the
just
right size of the good progress value
can be something that quickly give you
uh conversions to optimal weights. Okay.
So now let's look at the choice of batch
size. So if we choose the batch to be
small talking about maybe one which is
one example in each batch up to 32 this
is considered as a small batch size. The
good thing about this is this is highly
noisy. So like I said we like this. This
means that we explore the space of
parameters better and that can lead to
better generalization. Right? So this is
a plus. What's the disadvantage of this?
Well, like we said, this is slow. The
convergence will be slow. This is not
efficient
for our GPUs.
And if we increase the batch size to
some medium size, something between the
standard value 32 to 256,
this is considered a good balance.
And also this is actually very efficient
on hardware. However, the noise uh is
not as much as before and uh this not
this is not good because we may skip or
not uh discover better local minimas.
So what if we increase the the batch
sizes to large values?
This can be give us uh faster
conversions but the exploration is less
than before and in this case we may
overfeed.
So so far we discussed this uh vanilla
version of SGD.
There are ways to uh improve this
algorithm.
The main reason and the main problem
with uh this SGDs like we discussed in
the uh choice of batch size they can
oscillate in narrow valleys and they can
progress slowly because the only thing
that they have to control their
conversions is this alpha here. So we
can add more options to improve this.
One options is adding momentum. By
adding momentum I mean so instead of the
initial W's we uh update the momentum
based on the gradient.
So this is known known as velocity
update which then will uh do the update
on the parameters.
Here we call beta uh momentum
coefficient that can take values uh
typically between 0.9 and 99.
So the the intuition for u this momentum
based uh SGD is basically um imagine
like a ball rolling downhill.
it builds up speed in consistent
directions and rolls through small
bumps. So this way it will be more
consistent and uh may have the more and
faster uh desirable conversions
properties. One variation of u this
modern SGD algorithm that we will use a
lot during the course is known as ADA.
The ATOM stands for adaptive moment
estimation and it combines momentum with
adaptive learning rates for each one of
these parameters. Like I said, momentum
helps SGD to navigate this narrow
valleys basically escape from them
efficiently by accumulating velocity in
cons consistent directions. In this case
basically but what we mean by momentum
is uh the algorithm accumulate this past
gradients
and adaptive rates uh basically scale
the learning rate for each parameter
based on gradient history.
There is a bias correction where uh
accounts for initialization bias. So as
you will see Adam will be our go-to
option most of the time uh because of
all of these properties we may uh employ
learning rate scheduulers that basically
uh control
this uh step sizes and reduce um them
for more fine tuning over the training.
So if you want to give a summary uh to
this section, we start from some W. Most
of the time we start from random uh
values for for W.
Then for each epoch, we basically look
at the data and and extract a mini
batch. And for each one of this mini
batch, we calculate the loss. And this
is known as the forward pass.
And
this basically give us the loss.
And then we need to have a way for uh
calculating the the gradient uh uh which
is basically as you will see in the next
uh lecture. We call this a backward pass
that give us the gradient and the
average gradient for that mini batch.
And then having that we can update the
weights
and then check if this is a convergence.
If not we have to continue uh for the
next epoch.
So this is the no if it's converge then
we are